it's michelle of lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd cosmetic chemist and
professional sunscreen video maker
i have talked a ton about sunscreen over the years
but i've found that on every sunscreen video
i get asked questions that i've answered in
another video and i think it's because i've gotten
a lot of new followers so hi welcome and thank you
so i thought i'd do a video where i tried
to cover every sunscreen question that's
relevant to wearing sunscreen which i realized
four and a half thousand words into the script
is a very lofty goal and i'm sure the moment
i publish this video i'll think of three more
so here is almost all your
sunscreen questions answered
like and subscribe so you don't miss out
on me answering those three
questions that i forgot about
i've done tons of videos and blog
posts on sunscreen i also have
an ebook that has a sunscreen chapter
so i'll be summarizing a lot of things
i'll put links to the more detailed
explanations in the description
so please check that before you send
me comments saying i'm talking out my
let's get into it
when do i need to wear sunscreen?
i'm not your mum so you don't need
to do anything however these are
the official australian guidelines which are a
collaboration between experts from dermatology
as well as from endocrinology bone health and
cancer the world health organization has similar
guidelines as well and they're meant to balance
the health risks and the benefits of sun exposure
so skin cancer versus the benefits which is
mostly vitamin d production they recommend
that when the uv index is three or above in the
middle of the day you should use sun projection
if you go outside for more than a few minutes
even with sun protection you'll probably still
produce enough vitamin d when the uv index is
below 3 then sun protection is not recommended
and they recommend that you go outdoors in the
middle of the day with uncovered skin on most days
now these guidelines are very general and it's
just for skin cancer risk so wearing sunscreen
when the uv index is three or above is sort of
like bare minimum stuff and the evidence points
towards sunscreen specifically not making that
much of a difference when it comes to vitamin
d production all the little bits of your body
that don't get covered in enough sunscreen will
make vitamin d when you're in the sun anyway so
if you're trying to improve your skin and deal
with skin concerns like acne uneven pigment
premature aging so fine lines and wrinkles
which i'm guessing you are since you're watching
this video then you probably should wear sunscreen
on your face every day if you're going outside
the sun's uv is the biggest preventable cause
of skin aging and pigmentation prevention is much
easier and more effective than trying to undo the
damage later and it's usually cheaper as well this
is especially the case when it comes to deeper
damage that you need procedures to tackle and not
just skin care if you're not wearing sunscreen
it means that your skincare products have to
work harder to get results it's like they're
swimming upstream against the current so if you
use sunscreen to block out a bunch of that uv
stop some of that current in this analogy
then your products will be able to work better
there's actually a study that found that
skin texture clarity and pigmentation
improved with just wearing sunscreen daily so
your skin has the ability to repair itself if
you cut down the amount of uv smashing into
it sunscreen is especially important if you're
using skincare products with alpha hydroxy acids
like glycolic and lactic acids these chemical
exfoliants actually make your skin more sensitive
to uv so if you're not wearing sunscreen as well
it can actually mean your anti-aging skincare is
making your skin age faster which is really rude
what should i look for in a sunscreen?
basically all it comes down to is is it protective
enough for what you're doing and is it comfortable
and budget friendly enough that you'll wear enough
of it so let's start with protection the most
important thing is spf spf tells you how well
the sunscreen protects against burning which is
mostly to do with shorter wavelengths
of uv called uvb these are also the most
damaging rays of uv as well as burning they
cause skin cancer and premature skin aging
higher spf is better the protection you
get is proportional to that spf number
that's why spf ratings were designed the way
they are the whole spf 30 already protects
against 97% of uv is a myth for most people spf
30 is enough for an everyday sunscreen but you
might want high protection if you're getting a
lot of sun or if you just want higher protection
the downside of higher spf is that the formulas
can be a bit thicker and less nice to wear
but this has been improving a lot in the last
five years uva protection is also important uva
refers to the longer lower energy wavelengths
of uv that cause less burning but they're still
linked to skin aging cancers and increased pigment
production uva protection is a bit trickier than
spf because there isn't really a universally
agreed upon way of measuring uva protection and
some countries like australia actually don't let
brands show more detailed uva protection numbers
there are a lot of different labels used
in different places so i'm just going to
show a summary on screen and you can check my uva
video for more info basically you want to go for
at least broad spectrum if you care a lot about
hyperpigmentation or premature aging you'll want
to look for higher uva protection water resistance
is the final special sunscreen label that's
regulated it tells you how much spf protection
is left after sitting in water for a particular
amount of time in general more water-resistant
sunscreens are also more resistant to other things
like sweat sand rubbing and movement so it's
a good idea to use water-resistant sunscreen
if you're obviously getting into the water
but also if you're just moving around a lot
while getting sun exposure water resistance
is a bit tricky because different regions
have different rules even though the label is the
same australia and the us have the strictest ones
now if you have darker skin so fitzpatrick four
or above and you're worried about pigmentation
you might want to use a tinted sunscreen to
protect against visible light from the sun
physical sunscreens without a tint aren't very
good for this and tinted chemical sunscreens work
about as well as tinted physical sunscreens it's
really just about that tint tinted sunscreens
aren't really regulated for visible light
protection so it's hard to say which one is best
foundation probably works great for this as well
aside from protection it's really just personal
preference with things like texture white cast
skin sensitivity and cost you need a sunscreen
that you enjoy enough to apply regularly and that
you can afford to apply regularly because you do
need to apply quite a bit of sunscreen texture is
incredibly important and i think quite underrated
these days there are lots of really nicely
textured sunscreens that give great protection
they can feel just like primer or moisturizer
if a sunscreen has a texture that you hate
it's more likely to just sit on the shelf unused
and you're less likely to apply enough of it
there's a lot of talk about chemical
versus physical sunscreens but
they're actually really similar and
the things that i've already mentioned
are way more important my very general
rule of thumb is if your biggest problem
with sunscreen is texture or white cast i would
recommend trying a chemical sunscreen first but
if your biggest problem is irritation then i
would recommend trying a physical sunscreen first
there are also combination sunscreens which
have a mix of chemical and physical filters
they tend to be somewhere in between
the two for texture and white cast
i personally use a few different categories
of sunscreen for different situations
i have everyday sunscreens that are light and
comfortable they sit really nicely under makeup
and they don't clog my pores that much for me
these have to be above spf 30 they have to have
good uva protection and i prefer newer filters
that are less irritating to my skin and eyes
i also have hardcore face sunscreens
that i use for outdoor activities when
i don't really care how i look and
sun protection is really that priority
these are spf 50 plus broad spectrum and water
resistant i also have hardcore sunscreens for
my body for outdoor activities these are also
spf 50 plus broad spectrum and water resistant
but also relatively cheap so i'm not tempted to
apply less to save money ideally these also work
for my face so i don't have to mess around
with two bottles when it's time to reapply
i have a video with my favorite
sunscreens from last year and i've
added a few to the list since then
these are all in the description
how much sunscreen do i apply
to get the spf on the label?
you have to apply two milligrams per
square centimeter which works out to be
a bit less than a quarter teaspoon for just
your face for most people since the amount
you need depends on your face size the actual
amount will be a bit different for everyone
you can try to measure your face but it is a
bit of effort so if in doubt just aim for a
quarter teaspoon you might have heard of using
two fingers of sunscreen obviously the amount
depends a lot on how thick your lines are so if
you're not sure you can try scraping your lines
into a quarter teaspoon measure the reason you
have to apply so much is that your skin is bumpy
so if you don't apply enough then the
sunscreen sits in the valleys on your skin
and the hills don't get covered or the layer
just ends up way too thin a little goes a long
way just doesn't work with sunscreen it's like
a paint that you're wearing to hide your skin
from the sun if you don't have enough paint
on then parts of your skin will be exposed
for the rest of your body there are a lot
of different recommendations for how much
you need to apply because different places use
different estimates for different sized people
and chances are your proportions don't match
the ones they calculated for so when in doubt
just apply more than you need my favourite
version is the cancer council version because
i think it's the easiest one to memorize
it's one teaspoon for each of these parts
how do i actually apply sunscreen?
now for actually applying it i think it's really
helpful to remember that sunscreen works best when
it's in a smooth even undisturbed layer so
with that in mind it probably makes the most
sense to put sunscreen on your skin after skin
care regardless of what type of sunscreen it is
chemical sunscreens don't need to absorb
into bare skin to activate and work the only
exception is if it's a special type of long wear
sunscreen that's meant to absorb into your skin
those usually form a film in the
top of your skin so you probably
don't want tons of skincare under or over
it use your skin care a few hours earlier
try to make sure the sunscreen is evenly spread
over your skin you can dab it onto the different
parts of your face at the start you don't want to
rub too much there's a study showing that rubbing
reduces protection so apply it evenly and then
let it dry down don't rub it in the whole time
you should also apply all sunscreens before you go
outside sunscreens don't need time to activate but
they do need time to settle down and not get
wiped off onto your clothes or get disturbed
by too much moving it's a lot like wet paint
the recommendation is usually 15 minutes but
it depends on the sunscreen in one study the
sunscreen they used only needed eight minutes
how do i apply sunscreen when i'm
also wearing skincare and makeup?
sunscreen makes the most sense in between
skincare and makeup so your skincare can
sink into your skin and not mess up your sunscreen
and so your sunscreen doesn't mess up your makeup
again i think it's really helpful to remember that
sunscreen works best when it's in a smooth even
undisturbed layer there aren't a lot of studies
done on wearing sunscreen with other products
but based on studies for other situations it
seems like anything under the sunscreen but
especially on top of the sunscreen can mess up
your sunscreen layer so try to minimize the amount
of skincare you're using under the sunscreen so
keep it to one or two products and minimize the
makeup that you use on top of the sunscreen
again try to wait for the sunscreen layer to
flatten down and stick to your skin before you
apply your makeup maybe 5-10 minutes and try to
apply your makeup as gently as possible it's also
probably best to use a sunscreen with a higher spf
than you need so if it drops from the makeup
then you'll still be getting the spf you want
how can you stop sunscreen from balling up?
when sunscreen balls up it's usually
a interacting with your skincare b
drying too fast or c you're rubbing
it too much so you can try a applying
it on bare skin b applying on massively
moisturized skin or c patting it on gently
unfortunately my skin is really oily and sometimes
my own face oil is actually what's making it ball
up and people with dry skin have no problems
with the same sunscreen so if you've tried
the above and none of that worked i would
just try a different sunscreen i've found
so many that work well on my skin even though
i think i have a really ball-prone skin type
how do i look less shiny with sunscreen on?
a lot of sunscreens are oily because a lot of
sunscreen actives are oils or dissolved in oils
so if you blot away the oil you're probably
going to remove some sunscreen as well
the best way i've found to reduce shine without
lowering the protection too much is to wait for
the sunscreen to set and then gently pat on some
translucent powder on top i really like starch
based powders for this and this can also soak
up any extra oil that i produce during the day
and i would also recommend just looking for
a less shiny sunscreen to buy the next time
can i use blank instead of sunscreen?
you might have some products that say spf on
them and you're wondering if you can use them
instead of sunscreen the answer is usually no the
main thing to remember is you need to apply about
a quarter teaspoon to your face and some products
just don't really work that way for applying that
much foundation with spf this is what you
look like when you apply the proper amount
i usually apply about 1/8th of
this a very sheer foundation
might potentially work but i haven't found one
that doesn't do this powder with spf it just
doesn't stick to your skin enough this is what
it looks like when you apply the right amount
the powder that works best is probably the
colorescience powder that's designed for this
but even then their evidence doesn't really
convince me that you can apply enough
things that do work moisturizer with
spf if you can apply the right amount
this depends on the moisturizer
texture but in terms of the formula
sunscreens are the same as moisturizers
with spf they just chose a different name
to put on the label body sunscreens yes
you can use body sunscreens on your face
and face sunscreens on your body the only
minor issue is that body products tend
to spread more easily and be a bit heavier
but if you're fine with that then it's fine
uv protective clothing is fantastic but
obviously some skin is usually uncovered
regular clothes can work as well depending on
the fabric hats and umbrellas are useful but
most of the uv you get actually gets bounced from
the sky rather than coming directly from the sun
so the lower parts of your face actually get a
lot less protection so these are good to use in
conjunction with sunscreen to add extra layers of
protection think of it like layers of swiss cheese
layering enough types of imperfect protection
will give you pretty good protection overall
can i mix sunscreen with foundation
or moisturizer or another sunscreen?
it's best not to mix sunscreens with any other
products even though it can make it feel nicer or
get rid of white casts or make your routine faster
it changes the way the sunscreen dries which can
mean you get holes in your protection sunscreens
are emulsions like mayonnaise if you have the
wrong proportions then the emulsion can break
and separate if you've ever seen how foundation
can bunch up if you apply it over the wrong
product the same thing can happen to sunscreen
and if that's happening on a microscopic level
you won't be able to spot it and stop doing it
it's best to just look for a sunscreen that
already does what you want if you don't want
white cast then go for a chemical sunscreen if
you want a tint then go for tinted sunscreen
even worse are those sunscreen drop
products that you're meant to mix into
a moisturizer to make your own sunscreen
this means that you have this holey film
issue plus you end up applying so little
of it that you end up with really low spf
can i make my own diy sunscreen?
so i mentioned the sunscreen drop products that
you mix into other products end up with really
low protection and unreliable film formation
there are also diy sunscreen recipes that involve
mixing zinc oxide powder or diaper cream into oils
or moisturizers to get around 20% zinc oxide which
matches the percentage in a store-bought sunscreen
this doesn't work because protection isn't about
the percentage of the active ingredients
it's also about how they're distributed in
the sunscreen and how that applies on the skin
sunscreen uses special grades of zinc oxide with
very small particles this makes it absorb more uv
and it can also cover a larger area even with 20%
of this special zinc oxide mixed with industrial
equipment that can make the zinc oxide spread
out more evenly in the sunscreen sunscreen
formulators still get low spf sometimes this
is because the base isn't keeping that zinc oxide
spread out properly when you apply it to your skin
so sunscreen formulators can't get consistently
high spf with all of this special stuff the chance
of you getting it right consistently at home
with the wrong kind of zinc oxide is not great
can i use expired sunscreen?
there's no guarantee the sunscreen will be
working after the expiry date so i would
recommend throwing expired sunscreen out also
don't store sunscreen in the heat it can break
down and separate even before it expires which
means you won't get even protection so don't store
it in your car glove box and if you're at the
beach or at the park try to keep it in the shade
do i need to reapply sunscreen?
the main reason you need to reapply sunscreen is
that the sunscreen layer gets less even over time
like foundation the sunscreen layer clumps
up over time because your skin is moving
and producing sweat and oil underneath that
means you'll start getting tiny gaps in your
sunscreen layer that the uv can get through some
of the sunscreen also evaporates into the air and
absorbs into your skin so that sunscreen layer
will get thinner and less effective sunscreen
can also get wiped off onto things and if you
wet the sunscreen layer that can also clump up
even if it's a water resistant sunscreen so
after you've had your sunscreen on for two hours
you're probably not getting that label protection
anymore which is an issue if you're about to get
more sun exposure important note this is
two hours of the sunscreen being on your
skin not two hours of sun exposure there's
this misconception that reapplying sunscreen
is because the sunscreen ingredients stop
working after absorbing two hours of sun
this is a myth most sunscreens are pretty
photostable now so the ingredients almost
always keep working for longer than
the sunscreen film takes to clump up
this two hours is also just a general rule
there's evidence that some sunscreens can
last a lot longer and obviously if you're
sweating or moving around a lot and your
sunscreen isn't water resistant it probably
won't be staying put if you aren't moving
around a lot then you probably still have
pretty decent protection after a few hours
but no one's tested the protection for a
wide range of sunscreens so it's really hard
to say how much and unfortunately you can't
really rely on what you see with a uv camera
uv cameras don't have enough resolution to
tell what's going on and they work on uva
only one study found that the uv photo looked
exactly the same even with around 15% less spf
how do i reapply sunscreen?
i think reapplying sunscreen on your body
is pretty straightforward but how do you
reapply it on your face and how do you do
it if you're wearing makeup unfortunately
there isn't really a perfect way to get high
protection while keeping your makeup intact
so i approach it depending on how much
sun exposure i'm going to get afterwards
situation one is if i'm getting a lot of
sun exposure say i'm going on a long beach
walk in the afternoon then i keep my makeup
simple and just reapply the full amount of
sunscreen like normal every two hours
followed by minimal makeup you don't
have to wash off your sunscreen you can
just reapply on top but if there's dirt
on your face or if it's just getting a bit
messy you can wipe it off before you reapply
situation two is if i'm getting some sun and i
want to keep my makeup mostly intact say it's
summer and i'm walking outside for 20 minutes
after work then i reapply sunscreen on top of my
makeup right before i go out there are only really
two options for this that i think give enough
protection the option i prefer is reapplying
a light regular sunscreen over my makeup
i use a cushion puff which is a method that jude
of 50 shades of snail came up with around 2015
i really love these because they're so thin
they're really portable and they don't absorb
much sunscreen it is still good to use a bit more
sunscreen than normal to make up for what ends up
in the sponge there are sunscreen cushions
from asian brands as well that are designed
for reapplying over makeup but i find those too
expensive plus they usually have a white cast
the other option that can give decent coverage is
a spray sprays can get into the valleys of your
skin but the main issue is that sprays can be a
bit light in some spots so you need to make sure
you apply enough layers so if you're using a spray
make sure you apply enough layers let each layer
dry down before you apply the next layer you can
spray your spray into a quarter teaspoon measure
to work out how many sprays you need the other
issue is that breathing in too much sunscreen
probably isn't very good for you so if you use
a spray make sure you hold your breath and walk
out of the cloud of spray before you breathe
in again also be careful if it's too windy
because the spray just won't land on your skin i
would also avoid aerosol sunscreens the spf test
is usually done before adding propellant so you
need to apply a lot more to get that labelled
protection for re-application it's always safest
to go with a sunscreen that has similar active
ingredients to what you're already wearing
there's a slight chance that the sunscreen
actives can react with each other and break
down if you aren't mixing them around a lot
then it shouldn't be a huge problem but
it is safest to try to avoid that anyway
situation 3 is when i get minimal sun so for
example i'm going outside for 5 minutes and
it's mostly shady in that case i don't
reapply i rely on what i have on already
and just try to stay in the shade you can
also use those layers of protection so hats
shades sunglasses umbrellas are great if you
don't think your reapplication was quite enough
and also just generally when
you're getting a lot of sun
can i transfer sunscreen
into a different container?
i would really recommend not doing
that especially not for a long time
a lot of sunscreen ingredients can react with or
soak into some plastics this means you can end up
with less active ingredients in the sunscreen and
the sunscreen can dry in weird ways on your skin
glass should be okay if it's very clean
and if you keep it protected from light
how do i deal with eye sting?
some sunscreens can sting your eyes and annoyingly
it seems to be different ingredients
and sunscreens for different people
there are some sunscreens out there that don't
sting your eyes much so look at reviews for those
but if you've found the perfect sunscreen
apart from eye sting you can use a different
sunscreen for around your eyes i like to use
a zinc oxide sunscreen stick because they tend
to stay put for longer and zinc oxide tends to
not make your eyes water some people also find
that setting their sunscreen with translucent
powder helps but that isn't quite enough for me
do i need to wear sunscreen indoors?
probably not you probably aren't
getting enough uv inside your house
window glass blocks almost all the uvb but uva
can still come through and that can potentially
cause premature aging and increased pigment but
the roof and the walls are probably blocking the
vast majority of it unless you have sunlight
directly hitting your skin through a window
or if you're sitting next to a big window and you
can see lots of sky through it monitors and phone
screens don't produce enough damaging light to
worry about unless you have a special condition
and you would know if you have one of these
fluorescent lights also don't produce much uv if
they're properly shielded maybe be careful if you
have a bare bulb particularly an older curly bulb
there are a lot of other myths about sunscreen
that i haven't covered here and i'm
sure there'll be even more to come
but here is a list of myths that i've debunked
before i've linked the long versions in the
description but here is my attempt to speedrun
the more common ones in 20 words or less each
"chemical sunscreens are dangerous hormonal
disruptors" legal limits based on all relevant
data in context with large margin of safety
fear-mongering sites show select studies only
"nanoparticles are dangerous"
nanoparticles don't penetrate
beyond the stratum corneum with unbroken skin
"chemical and physical sunscreens work
differently" both mostly work the same
only five to ten percent uv is scattered
by physical sunscreens the rest is absorbed
"physical sunscreens work better"
how well sunscreen works depends on
spf and uvapf chemical sunscreens
can get higher spfs and uvapfs
"heat from chemical sunscreens
is bad for melasma" chemical
and physical sunscreens produce around
same heat that amount is undetectable
"some sunscreens aren't reef safe"
climate change agricultural pollution
overfishing are killing reefs way too little
sunscreen in ocean to make a difference
"sunscreens contain carcinogenic
benzene" amounts in sunscreen are
tiny you get more from parking your
car in a garage attached to your house
if i didn't answer something in enough detail
i've probably covered it in a different video
i've done a lot of sunscreen videos
and blog posts and instagram posts
if you want more practical specifics about finding
and using sunscreen and setting up a
skincare routine check out my ebook
if you're a sunscreen nerd the sunscreen e summit
is coming up it's a free conference on may 15th
hosted by me and jen of the eco well we've locked
in talks from some of the top sunscreen experts
in the industry i'll be talking about sunscreen
mythbusting it is going to be an incredible event
so make sure you book in for that and check out
more videos from me coming up on the side here